because fundamentally what you're trying
to do is you're trying to balance
between
safety of your users and giving people a
voice
[Music]
thank you so much for being on my show
how are you i'm doing great how are you
how have you been doing this crazy time
you know i've been um
i've been it's been a difficult and very
challenging time
but i was i'm trying to make the most of
it so
i've learned how to cook out of sheer
need
and my cooking skills have just
skyrocketed to a point where
you can actually eat my food
that's pretty fantastic i think it's
always fascinating for me to see how
every person interacts differently
you know i was just talking about it
with a family recently but how
you know it's crazy how we all have this
you know collective crisis and every
person now manages it differently but
alone
one thing that is different from your
daily life is that you
are a big traveler and you actually
traveled to 30 different countries
writing a book about coffee now for
context you're also a director
within facebook ai yet you go and you
are writing a book about coffee what is
that all about
well so um good question
so the book was actually written and i
was working for google
okay google gets the
credit google gets the credit um
you know i think i have no good
explanation for why i decided
uh at some point in my 40s that i need
to write a book about coffee
i always like to go to cafes i always
like the vibe in cafes
and i always feel like i always notice
that in different countries
you go you get different experiences in
cafes
and so i was very curious about trying
to map that and study it a little more
detail
why am i getting these different
experiences and then i did something
which ultimately led to writing a book i
started telling my friends
that i think i should write a book about
coffee and
after a few months my friends have come
start coming back to you and say hey
and once you once you sort of sign a
social contract you have no choice but
to
do it alone i love that so much i
created a google map and i um and i
listed through 30 different countries
that one must visit in order to write a
book about coffee
many of them i was traveling to or to
the area anyway because
uh because of the nature of my job right
but uh
some of them i actually had to take a
few days off that's that's hilarious how
do you on how many how many cups do you
drink a day
just for context me too but they're very
high quality only two
only two if i'm at a coffee conference
which hey these things exist a coffee
conference
that must be one hell of an energy in
that auditorium
yes so then i would drink somewhere
between
10 and 15 uh
okay and before we move on to you know
technology and high tech what is your
favorite coffee you've ever tried in
your life
the country in place uh
the favorite is from a region called the
yoga chef
okay ethiopia um
it came from a one of the
cooperatives
one of the hardest transitions i've had
coming from tel aviv to palo alto i have
to i have to admit
is getting used to not having my fuch in
the morning and my cappuccino so that
was definitely a big change but alone we
only have 15 minutes left i've wasted
way too much about coffee
take me through your journey you start
out as an entrepreneur move on to
researcher
and you know go through these incredible
companies like google now facebook bell
labs
what what is why are you so curious
about
your domain expertise you're also a
professor at university of washington
walk me through your journey a little
bit okay um so i had um
i had no doubt in life that i needed to
be a professor
really my father was a professor it
looked like
the right job to do so i never actually
had a point in my life where i had a
hard decision to make interesting
it was obvious that i wanted to do a phd
at stanford of course
of course and then after i finished my
phd nobody gave me a professor job
so i went to what was at the time of a
pretty prestigious lab called att
bell labs and a few years later um
i got an offer to be a professor at the
university of washington wow and i went
here
then i realized that this is what in the
height of the 90s when
when all these startups were going on is
this where you actually met my father
back in bell labs okay
okay now making the connection yeah yeah
your father and i were
both part of the database community
right the academic database i've known
him since
i graduated maybe even before wonderful
and so why why
so first of all did the professorship
live up to your expectations why did you
want to be a professor i mean
yeah your father was a professor but
what attracted you to academia
so much as you're seeing you know the
dot-com you know
rise and obviously the bubble but
everything rise
you know i think at the very um
at my very core i like to think about
new ideas
breaking ground and and sort of
ask the questions that will lead other
researchers and
engineers and companies to think about
the next
generation of products so to do that
um being a professor is a good
is a good place to do that right i
really enjoyed working with students
students i had some
pretty awesome students at the
university of washington
um and it was you know it's i'd still
recommend it i mean being a professor is
um you can do much worse right of course
i had an entrepreneurial
bone in my body yeah so take me three or
two companies the second one was
acquired by google i believe right
that's when you joined google
yes okay the second company was based on
a
project that we did at the university of
washington uh
we developed some technology that
enabled search engines to actually crawl
beyond
forms on on web pages if you saw a form
until then yeah
you needed a human to actually fill in
the fields of the form and to get all
the comments
we developed a method that um uh
that was able to do that automatically
and therefore
add many more high quality pages
to the google index at the time and
we're actually still looking back and
you know it's 2005 2006 right these are
the
these are around the time so so it's
still very early and you know
i i very few people talked about web
development and websites just became a
thing
um that is true that is true um
it's now that i think back at it that's
uh that's a good point
um we still didn't understand
right web search was still even though
google was already a public company when
i joined it
uh web search was still in its writing
and it was a really i remember at the
time
was an extremely exciting place to be
yeah i'm sure i'm sure
people were coming up with i just had a
very fascinating chat with them marcel
cronucker from
from um apache impala and he mentioned
that he was you know at google also in
around 2003 2004 working on databases
and how exciting it was at that time
when it was just people are
understanding what's the potential alone
give me your two cents quickly about
this integra
this intersection between academia and
startups you're working on research as a
part of academia which
naturally flows into the high-tech scene
you formed a company out of your work in
university of washington
stanford professors are very well known
to do this type of thing andrew ing i
believe runs about 10 or 11 different
startups at the same time
so talk to me so what what is this is
there a dissonance
do they want you to do this is this
frowned upon
so that is something that has uh
over the years the universities
universities realize that
um this is a good thing for them right
okay
so you know if you go back even 20 25
years it was a difficult thing to do
universities like stanford and mit you
really realized early on that
being part of that ecosystem um is an
important thing for
for uh to be involved in
and then you know then you get a bunch
of lawyers in the room right and so
it takes a while to work out the process
and to make sure that
everybody is right that's the right
credit the university gets a cut the
students that were involved get it cut
whatever all these things worked out so
over
um and also universities were letting
faculty leave for you for a year or two
to work on their company and then come
back
okay which is really important because
it's very hard to start a
successful company and not be full-time
at the company
especially if you're if you're the
founder right um so i don't think
i think today is very different than
what it was when you know like
15 or 20 years ago i think today it's
sort of taken
for granted that people are gonna do
this um
and i think the process is much more
well established but again it varies by
by university and country and um
it's not it's not easy everywhere all
right okay so you know let's
i'd like to fast forward to to present
day you're
you're at your director within at the
facebook ai group and
you know everybody talks about ai and
especially now as we're approaching you
know 2020 is a monumental year not just
because covet
which is a very data driven pandemic
right i mean the whole world is trying
to figure out what the hell is happening
but also we have elections coming up and
you have you know data is just playing
such a more significant role in our
lives
and more and more and that's something
that i'm very curious about within
stanford
at the level of a director and with your
experience in the field and with the
responsibilities that you hold
talk to me a little bit about why you're
passionate about
the field of artificial intelligence and
maybe a little bit about
our responsibility as we develop
responsible and
ethical ai um
wonderful topic i'm totally into that
right now
um so
the short answer is there's never been a
time in history where ai is so crucial
to the continuing functional behavior of
humanity
okay so so let me let me be very
specific yes
social networks are awesome right they
enable anybody to have a voice
right they enable whether it's a famous
person or your next door neighbor
anybody can say anything you can start
connecting with people in other parts of
the world that share confidence that
you've never
met before wonderful
wonderful social value right
no argument there yeah okay but there's
always a button when there's a great
technology right um
social networks also are a
window into the worst in humanity
whether it is people
putting up hate speech people creating
and disseminating this information right
people
avoiding other people for uh
you know for various that
um various things that i don't even have
to mention
uh people trying to sell illegal uh
items on on
social networks so the number and we
call these violations these are
right policy violation but you know i
mean i think that the big thing here is
that we're talking about
scale so it's you know you can you can
have a thousand people sitting around
and reading and reading every post but
when you get
to millions or billions of posts a day
at that scale it becomes a a feat right
yes and and so so this problem is known
as the problem
of preserving integrity right networks
okay and hopefully in a few weeks from
now there will be a survey that
my colleagues and i uh and facebook
will have finished writing about this
topic so we're releasing this video
after the survey is published so that i
can put the link there because i'm sure
it'll be fascinating
oh we have time covert is here to stay
for a long time don't worry this show is
going to go on
okay good so um
it is crucial it is crucial to the
social networks
to keep the the content on the network
safe for
the users right right and as you uh
pointed out
doing this manually is impossible right
so so what we have is we have a bunch of
ai systems that are constantly looking
at content coming in okay when they are
very with these ai systems are extremely
confident that this
this content is violating they will
remove it automatically
when they are not confident or when they
will receive a user flag so
users will see content right yes yes
we will send it to a large number of
paid workers who will look at it and see
whether it violates
my policy by the way in terms of the
ripeness of the technology and of course
if i ever ask something
that is not suitable for here let me
know but in terms of ripeness of the
technology
where does the where are we at now is it
more so
on the automatic flagging or more so on
the
on the user flagging uh we
catch we uh so facebook actually
publishes uh
uh every six months a report on on the
number
okay okay so actually some of these
uh there are like tens of different
violations
right now i should say coming up with
policies
for what is allowed and what is not
allowed that by itself
yes and i'm not is to talk about that
because that's going to get me
on a rat hole that i i'm not authorized
to go there okay
but you can imagine right this is this
is a really really it's based on culture
it's based it's there's so many so yeah
it's like the trolley problem the
classic problem yeah
yes and because it's fundamentally what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
balance between
safety of your users and giving people a
voice yes
yes very small nuances for example you
are not allowed to advertise
uh to sell uh guns on facebook
that's part of the policy but if you're
a gone
retailer you're allowed to talk about
what's available in your store
and it's those nuances are crazy but
alone i do want to save some time also
for thinking a little bit broader about
the world of ai and where we're headed
as a society so yes
you've got to see both google and
facebook and wow that's your domain
expertise now i want you i want to
extrapolate with you a little bit about
you know where what are my kids going to
experience in terms of their online
behavior
where do you see ai integrating into our
online environment you know as the years
develop because we'll get over our
current homes we'll get over the
elections and covet and everything
i want i want to know what you know my
kids can expect in terms of their
integrations
that's a great question um so
so let's let's put the integrity problem
in perspective first
yes so 30 years ago we had a huge
problem with spam
just mail spam yeah we don't really talk
about nail stam anymore
yeah sort of a solve problem the hope is
that all these integrity violations all
this hate speech and misinformation
it will be uh you know the way of the
past of like
it's a much much harder problem in terms
of of the eye
and and as you point out there's so many
things that are involved
but the hope is that it'll be it'll be
like stan
okay so now the question is
i think of it so to me integrity is
you come on to a social network if you
see something that violates the
the policies that's a negative
experience for us
okay our goal is to minimize the number
of negative experiences that you might
have on the flipping
right now let's look at the happy side
how can we increase or maximize the
number of positive experiences that you
have
okay and that's really where the
opportunity lies okay
how is it and i'm speaking here
not authorized by facebook does it just
i'm asking alona
of course okay how do i make it such
that a social network
or any ai tool just helps me be my best
self yeah any given point in the day
okay so now if i have a couple of hours
free and i'm not sure what to do
the computer knows what the weather is
and it knows what's open it knows
what i've enjoyed doing in the past
maybe something what i haven't done for
a while
i what i want is an ai system that knows
me so well but it's very private right
so we're not
we're not compromising on privacy i want
an ai system
that will give me advice at any given
point in the day
yeah it will enable me to be the best to
have the best
experiences that i can and by the way i
think privacy is such an interesting
issue and i say that because you know
i'm
i'm on the on the extreme end of i want
i want
everyone to know everything about me i
want them to know where i live what i do
where i work when i sleep when i brush
my teeth
i want to have the most personalized
experience in the world a lot of my
friends especially
like my age and older are very you know
conservative like we don't want
anybody to know we're very scared yet we
want so we want to enjoy
you know personalization but not at the
expense of privacy i'm saying my friends
that are younger than me now at stanford
because muslim are younger than me
and you know a lot of the people in in
israel
privacy you know i feel like the
generation is like we i
am like this listen the needle that's
about to move into the realm of
we want personalization we've under we
understand that you know in order to get
real personalization we have to
compromise a little bit of privacy
and we're all for it so i'm a big
advocate of that
good and then in that case i would
encourage you to to talk to your friends
and tell them to run for office and
but responsibly because right because it
has to be done responsibly obviously
it needs to be done responsible and
obviously fairness and and
biases and data because at the end of
the day you know
um we're susceptible to a variety of uh
biases in our algorithms as well this is
a field that we're
actively trying to figure out right now
alone what are you most passionate about
what excites you most
in your in your professional career
having technology help people in their
day-to-day lives
like you're seeing seeing the real
impact yes
so i want i want something that actually
makes a difference
that either reduces friction for me or
uh or makes my life better in some way
so so
alone i wanna that i like to work on
so you liked so but then again you know
you're working within companies that you
know
processes take time yet when you do get
it to accomplish something they roll out
to you know billions of users
so do you and do you prefer working for
a long time to get to that billing user
or do you prefer the more startup life
where every single day you're making a
positive impact on the product on the
team
it's not this or that um i think even
when you
even when you're working at a company
like google or facebook to get to that
billion users you're still working with
a small team and you're still working
with people and mentoring people
and taking people you know solving hard
problems every day
seeing people uh develop as their
careers
as they mature in their careers so
there's there's a lot of that
going on and at the same time publishing
uh papers that have impact on
right and that's more the research side
of you
um i think without that mix i would be
not be very happy and i think that's
also very interesting um
a very interesting collaboration between
you know the research part of you but
the product part of you
which is not always you know it doesn't
always go hand in hand
both you know a proper researcher a
professor in computer science
at the same time you know thinking about
the end user and how your products
impact humanity at the end
alone before we leave i want to thank
you again for your generous time really
so
and i have to ask you the most important
question which is three words that you
would use to describe yourself
uh things outside the box things outside
the box
it sound it sounds like that's a little
bit of what it takes to to you know be
to be a director within facebook ai
alone thank you very much
and and stay safe and stay healthy thank
you i'll see you around j adventures
we even forgot to talk about that but
i'll see you around
take care bye bye